vous savez c'est pas l'univers ou le
sandwich hot chicken qui choque le plus
un étranger qui arrive au québec c'est
ça ça c'est la logique canadienne pour
mesurer et oui c'est compliqué on va
vous mettre le schéma en lien dans la
version wii on sait qu'un m c'est plus
grand qu'un pied mais convertir avec
précision ça ne tendent pas tout le
monde alors pour la démonstration quoi
de mieux qu'une épicerie en plein coeur
du plateau le petit paris de montréal
hum ça entre un livre utile aux
chasseurs
65 67 kg
ça fait combien ça en livre
plusieurs niveaux captv
ça sent que ça c'est en pièces que vous
savez combien c'est en mètres non je ne
sais pas comment cela
ms oui train kidman cinquante ans plus
tard manifestement il ya un blocage
pourquoi on va lui demander son avis un
historien monsieur desrosiers lauzon
bonjour bonjour ça fait 50 ans ce livre
blanc est ce que ce système impérial
finalement peut-être qu'on veut pas s'en
débarrasser
l'attachement aux systèmes de mesure
c'est comme l'attachement au langage ça
quelque chose de très culturel
introduire un nouveau système de mesure
s'est cassé ce lien là avec des
attachements très intime qui remonte à
l'enfance quand j'étais jeune on allait
dans l'atlantique et d'eau et à 60 et 5
assists être très très froid faranah et
mes ressentis gratte je suppose et quoi
sert ces lois comme ça
bonjour assure même les plus experts
avaient un peu de mal au moment de la
transition
une petite pluie la savate m'ont bien de
mm par exemple et puis une puis moyenne
ils puymoyen de ce serait à est plus
compliqué c'est le genre d'erreurs qu'on
pardonne mais eu un problème de
conversion qui a bien failli se
transformer en catastrophe aérienne
c'était en 1983 un boeing 767 d'air
canada qui volaient entre montréal et
edmonton sauf que le remplissage en
carburant a été plus qu'approximatif on
s'est trompé d'un calcul on a utilisé la
mauvaise le mauvais multiplicateur pour
faire la conversion de litres
un livre à kg et résultat on avait deux
fois moins de carburant en est tombé en
panne sèche en plein vol il a réussi à
se poser sans faire de blessé à gimli au
manitoba
après avoir plané pendant des dizaines
de kilomètres aujourd'hui on a toujours
ça pour nous aider à convertir ce qui
nous vaut une réflexion presque
philosophique de notre historien lui qui
regrette que le système métrique n'est
pas triomphé complètement c'est quand
même si l'avancement technologique était
en recul en termes de modernité mais
finalement est-ce que ce n'est pas le
charme d'une société plurielle comme le
canada c'est comme les anglophones et
les francophones si l'on regarde de
cohabiter pourquoi pas deux systèmes
et puis une livre c'est quand même bien
moins cher qu'un kilo si mathieu prost
radio canada
[Musique]